World War III might break out any second  right now Russia is trying to make four  regions in East Ukraine officially a  part of Russia by holding bogus votes in  those regions that way if countries step  foot in those regions Russia can say  that they were the ones that committed  an act of war against Russia and attack  back in response to Ukraine just applied  to join NATO if that happens the U.S UK  Germany would have to join the war and  defend Ukraine on top of that the north  stream pipelines which were vlad's last  piece of Leverage to get what he wants  were just sabotaged and as crazy as it  sounds it might have been the U.S that  blew up the pipelines hence it has to do  with money subscribe for part two to  find out why